pas grave ou partager ce point de vue il
ya une justice à deux vitesses c'est à
dire que les serbes ont davantage été
condamné que l'ébauché 1,15 alors que ça
va je rappelle juste que vous avez
couvert sur les couverts tous ses cours
le diront que d'être mm ce qui nous
inquiète c'est grâce à renaud girard
quand j'ai compris quelque chose
voilà je voulais dire c'est que j'ai
effectivement couvert l'intégralité de
ce conflit rillettes deux choses
premièrement le général mladic est tout
à fait responsable du massacre de
srebrenica y aucun doute il est entré
dans l'enclavé qui était protégé par les
nations unies le 11 juillet 1995 et il
est ses troupes ont massacré dans les
deux semaines qui suivaient et j'ai même
mois interrogé plus tard en secret un
des massacreurs massacre et 7000 hommes
et garçons donc ce pas tarder à la
population féminine la population
masculine de cette enclave à ce que les
hommes en civil civil au lieu de les
faire partir ils pouvaient faire partir
les hommes et les femmes en même temps
vers tous à des femmes ont raison et les
enfants ont été dirigées les vieillards
ont été rédigées sur sur une zone
musulmane et donc c'est très bien qu'ils
soient qu'ils soient condamnés on aurait
aimé que ce soit plus tôt et puis la
plus cachée on aurait aimé que que voilà
qu'ils soient en meilleur état mais il
mérite tout à fait sa condamnation à
perpétuité c'est tout à fait certain en
revanche on regrette que ce tribunal sur
l'ex yougoslavie et pas effectivement
ait eu la main lourde uniquement vers en
les garder c'est remet donc ça fait
justice de vainqueur puisque finalement
ce sont des serbes ont perdu cette
guerre civile rudesse de la vie à la fin
et on regrette par exemple que au kosovo
donc c'est une guerre de l'otan n'est ce
pas en 1999 pour obliger la serbie a
lâché sa province du kosovo
alou checa albanaise
l'armée de libération des albanais qui
sont la majorité de la population de
cette province serbe du kosovo
il ya eu deux mille victimes 2000
vieillard en 2000 serbes civils qui ont
été massacrés par l'ofce cas où
enfin en tout cas en albanie et pas un
seul dirigeant de l'eau checa qui se
retrouvent d'ailleurs à diriger voit le
kosovo qui pensent comme un état
indépendant par un état-nation pas
reconnu par tout le monde mais qui est
reconnu par la france
on peut regretter effectivement que qu'
il ya eu une impunité et de même on peut
regretter aussi que l'ancien commandant
de srebrenica mais qui n'était pas là au
moment du massacre
parce qu'il avait été retiré parce qu'en
fait ça devait devait être donnée aux
serbes dans les cas en fait vous pas une
raison pour massacrer 7000 hommes voilà
lui-même a été élargie alors qu'il est
coupable d'un petit massage d'un petit
massaka kravitz a le 7 janvier 1993 où
le jour de noël nuit de noël les bosses
et les musulmans de srebrenica est allé
faire un raid ou avec les habitués ne
centaines de civils serbes dans ce
village c'est pas une raison
deux ans et demi après pour faire une
vengeance aussi énorme et tué sept mille
personnes en les magnifiant elizabeth je
voulais juste dire